ich war 15 jahre im gefängnis als ich
elf jahre 20 jahre neun monate fünf tage
für eine tat nicht begangen haben 3 von
300 in den usa unschuldig verurteilt wie
konnte das geschehen
warum kam sie ins gefängnis für taten
die sie nie begangen hatten
die organisation die in essens projekt
kümmert sich um solche fälle dass ihr
dna tests und analysiert die
hintergründe
jeder vierte unschuldig verurteilte
hatte die tat gestanden
obwohl er nicht der täter war
in anderen fällen waren es falsche
beweise falsche zeugenaussagen die zur
verurteilung führten sie zeigten dem
opfer fahndungsfotos alle in schwarz
weiß nur von mir zeigten sie dass
farbige ibm futter darauf konzentrierte
sich die frau fünf minuten später sah
sie mich in eine reihe mit den anderen
und identifizierte mich als angreifer
eine falsche zeugenaussage machte marvin
anderson zum verbrecher eine falsche
erinnerung eine fehlleistung des
gedächtnisses
wie es zu solch fatalen falschaussagen
kommen kann schildert ein buch das
zutiefst verstörend unsere erinnerungs
welten in frage stellt die in london
tätige rechts psychologin julia
schaukelten ihrem buch das trügerische
gedächtnis am wahrheitsgehalt von
geständnissen und zeugenaussagen oder
ein gut oder schlecht
so funktioniert das gehirn das punkt ist
auf unserer erinnerungsvermögen zu wenig
verlassen kann es sein dass wir uns
falsch erinnern dass wir uns an
ereignisse erinnern die in wirklichkeit
nie stattgefunden haben
julia erforscht wie das gehirn
unterschiedlicher informationen zur
erinnerung formen und sie ging in einem
experiment noch einen schritt weiter in
einer testreihe versuchte sie eine nie
stattgefundenen straftat in das
gedächtnis einer person einzupflanzen
die erste sitzung die junge frau sollte
ich an zwei ereignisse erinnern
zuerst an ein ereignis das wirklich
stattgefunden hat mit informationen von
den eltern der testperson schafft julia
chance vertrauen
dann wird sie nach dem zweiten
erfundenen ereignis befragt
ich kann mich nicht erinnern
ich weiß nicht wovon sie reden nun
beginnt julia show mit einer
erinnerungsreise und fragt nach
einzelheiten details aus der kindheit
stellen sie sich vor sie sind 14
ich schlage er dann vor reisen wieder
zurück
das 14-jährige sie stellen sie sich doch
vor wie es war als sie 14 jahre alt
waren
machen sie doch die augen zu es ist
herbst
sie sind in kolomna dennoch was kannst
du damals gesehen haben uns am ende des
ersten interviews sieht man wie sie ganz
klar daran arbeitet dieses diese
verschüttete erinnerungen wieder
auszugraben
aber man sieht dann auch am ende was sie
erzählt
das war wahrscheinlich in crawford
bereits am ende der ersten sitzung
formen sich erst erinnerungs fragmente
es folgen zwei weitere gespräche nach
dem gleichen muster und die erinnerungen
an das nie stattgefunden ereignis werden
immer klarer und konkreter die polizei
kam und wir gerieten in einen verbalen
streit hatten krach drei freundlichen
interviews menschen eingeredet sie
hätten eine straftat begangen passiert
ist so einfach geht's
70 prozent der testpersonen
funktionierte diese methode die ein
neues licht auf unsere fähigkeit zur
erinnerung wirft was ist wahrheit wie
wichtig wie wahrhaftig sind all die
details an die wir uns erinnern
spinnen wir ein gewebe von assoziationen
im gehirn welches wir später vielleicht
auf graf aufrufen können das problem ist
dass wir auch viele assoziieren mit
stücken die vielleicht gar nicht so
zusammen passen und so entstehen falsche
erinnerung wie flechten stücke zusammen
die nicht zusammenpassen
in einem strafprozess kann das fatale
folgen haben
aber auch im alltag sollten wir
nachdenken welche bedeutung wird der
erinnerung zu ordnen sind es fakten oder
eben nur bruchstücke aus der
vergangenheit die wären der gegenwart
neu interpretieren